-Our first guest tonight i
a Grammy-nominated
country-music superstar,
and coach on "The Voice."
The season finale airs
this Monday and Tuesday at 8:00,
here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-Blake, let me go with you, bud.
-What -- Where is the --
What camera?
What camera am I looking in?
-Just talk to America.
-America, this show is
called "The Voice."
When have you ever in your lif
heard a voice like that?
-Wow.
-Recognize it.
-So great.
-And reward it!
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back
to the show Blake Shelton.
How are you, Blake?
-Hey, Seth, you know what?
I was watching that clip
right there.
By the way, hello.
Good to see you.
But I just was reminded becaus
you came from the "SNL" world,
I was channeling my best
Chris Farley and Adam Sandler.
Remember The Herlihy boy?
-Absolutely.
-"Let the boy
babysit your grandma!"
-[ Laughs ]
"He's a good boy!"
-That's right, that's right.
-I had your beautiful fiancée --
Gwen was on the show in October.
I have a --
I have a small gripe,
which is, the very next day,
she basically announced
on Instagram
that you guys had been engaged
That's the kind of content
we could have really had
a lot of fun with.
Why did she wait
until the day she left?
-I remember this,
by the way, Seth,
because she did
your show from --
I believe she was in Oklahoma.
We have a little cabin there
that we stay in.
And believe it or not, somehow
I figured out how to get
Internet there.
And she -- And she kept, like,
doing this with her hand
and, you know, wondering
if people would figure out
that she was wearing
an engagement ring.
And I told her --
I said, "You know,
you wear more jewelry
than Mr. T.,
so I don't think anybody
is gonna pick up on that, Gwen."
[ Laughter ]
And they didn't.
You could have figured it out,
though.
She was giving you hints.
-I know.
It's very hard over Zoom,
because you never know.
I don't want to stare.
You end up looking in the camera
more than you do at the guests
So it was true.
It was right in front of me,
and I missed it.
I don't want to ask too much
about wedding plans.
But it does strike me
that with the two of you,
picking a wedding band
has very --
I mean, I'm assuming
you know a lot of people,
but that's a high-pressure gig
to be the wedding band
at your shindig.
-You know, I've kind of decide
that, you know, I've been
doing this a long time now
and I've got a lot of favors
out there.
And he may not like it,
but Adam Levine is going t
have to get the band togethe
and come and play our wedding.
I think that would be --
I've already seen a music vide
where they crash
people's weddings.
And he owes me, a lot,
for just putting up with him
over the years.
So maybe we can get Adam
to come be our wedding band.
Not "maybe." We are going to
-I think he should do that
And while he's playing,
I think you and Gwen
should turn your chairs around
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I like that idea.
-[ Laughs ]
-And plus, their music
is so boring,
that it won't distract
from the festivities
and the reception
and all that stuff.
-Right, you should maybe hav
them play in a separate barn
You know, like you can go over
if you want to relax a little.
[ Laughter ]
You and Gwen also just release
your second number-one singl
together.
When we were here,
we were talking about the fact
that you guys won a CMT Award.
-Yeah.
-And now, obviously, you know,
you have introduced her
to your genre of music.
It would be fun, and
I think your fans would enjoy,
just one ska song.
Just one.
-I knew that's where
you were going with this.
Can you imagine?
I don't even know.
I'm not even certain
what "ska" even means.
Like, is that like a --
Is that a genre?
Is that just a...
-Yeah, I would say,
it's sort of reggae-inspired
genre of music.
I think it's, like,
right in your wheelhouse.
-You know, maybe I could -
I don't even know, actually.
I was starting to say, maybe I
could get away with some reggae.
But I still don't think
I could perform.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Yeah.
-I did not know this about you
and I apologize,
but you're producing
a Hallmark movie.
This is your third.
And the part about it
that's fascinating to me -
it's a Christmas film -- you
produced it with your mother
-[ Chuckling ] That's true
That is fascinating,
isn't it, Seth?
-[ Laughs ]
I will say I love my mother.
I don't know if I would love
to produce a film with her
Especially a holiday film.
-The joys of working
with your mom in the
entertainment industry.
What happened was,
we wrote a song together.
I had a Christmas album that
came out several years ago
And my mom is a little bit
like Lucy Ricardo,
where she's
constantly harassing Ricky
to let her be on the show, o
let her sing or write a song
My mom has always
wanted to be a songwriter.
So she's always texting me o
talking to me about song ideas
So, finally, one day,
I said, "Look,
I'm making a Christmas album
I think it would be appropriat
for you and I to finally write
this Christmas song together
I'll record it.
It'll be on my album,
and we'll sing it like a duet.
And so we did this thing.
And then, they ended up --
Some publisher came along,
and offered her a book dea
because of this song.
And then, because
the book came out,
then the Hallmark Channel
came along
and they offered to do a movie
based on the book.
And the movie did good, an
here we are, three movies later.
So, just let me know
if you want to do any work
with any family members.
-Do you, um --
I do want to ask real quic
about this season
of "The Voice."
Coming in the homestretch,
you seem pretty well-positione
to take the crown again.
Are you feeling confident?
-[ Sighs ] I am.
You know, the problem
for Team Blake this year,
I have two members left,
which is incredible
in the finale.
Everybody else just has one.
But Gwen happens to have thi
very, very special young man
named Carter Rubin,
that I feel like,
if there's a threat to all o
our teams, it's that kid.
And if he wins, I don't thin
any of us would be mad about it,
because he deserves it,
he's a special kid.
But my team has been strong,
and they have been all season.
And we never know
how the voting is going.
They never clue us in.
You would think,
after almost 20 seasons
of doing this show,
I could pull some favors,
but I still never know
what's going on
behind the scenes.
So, I would say Carter
is going to be
our toughest competition,
all of us coaches,
'cause he's a special -- he'
got a pretty decent coach, too
-You know, it's incredible
to watch
the talent of the singers
on the show,
but I'm always taken, as well,
with the amount of nerve
they need to have to go ou
and perform live,
in front of --
even without an audience,
they're performing in front of
these four -- the four of you.
Do you think you would have ha
the confidence
to go out there at their age
and do what they do?
-You know, Seth, I honestly --
I think it's probably --
I put myself in their position
And no different than, you know,
how you're having to do
this show now,
things are, I feel like,
easier if you have an audience
versus four people
sitting out there,
and you get the...
You know, no matter what you do,
it sounds like
it was disastrous.
-[ Chuckling ] Right.
-We are in entertainment,
you know,
and there's
no immediate feedback.
There's nobody to go high-five
And so I think it's actually
harder this way.
When I was a kid, you know
I would get stage fright
to get onstage.
But once I got up there,
and I could can hear
some singing along
or see some smiling,
I kinda got over it.
So, I really feel for them
the way we're doing it now
I feel like it's
even more awkward
than, you know, getting onstag
in front of 2,000 people,
or however many we have
in our audience normally -
400, I think.
-Well, it's
a special group of people.
It's always a delight
to talk to you.
Thanks so much
for being here, Blake.
-You too, buddy.
Good to see you.
Have you had a chance to talk to
Brad Paisley in a while?
I know you guys are buddies.
-Yeah, you know,
we stay in touch via text.
I know he's probably
a lot like you.
He's just itching to
get back out there on the road
A guy who really likes being
in front of his audience.
Worked really hard
to get that audience,
and it's a shame that he's not
performing in front of them.
-Tell him I said, "Kiss my ass,"
next time you talk to him.
[ Laughter ]
Appreciate that.
-The season finale of
"The Voice"
airs Monday and Tuesday
at 8:00 on NBC.
We will be right back
with Jenny Slate.